grazie il mese scorso
a londra a un importante evento presso
l'open data institute questo non li ho
conosciuto la persona che vedete mezzo
nell'immagine tim berners lee inventore
del web
il motore del www ma pensa che sta
parlando anche molto tantissimo di
condivisione dell'idea dei dati da si
era avuto occasione di parlare con chi
berners lee di incontrarlo e di
confrontarmi con lui l'ho mostrato
questo oggetto qui che ha destato
tantissimo la sua curiosità così come
l'ha destata me il giorno in cui ho
ricevuto questo regalo qualche giorno
prima
questo oggetto qua è molto particolare
perché la mappa che sopra una mappa io
con street ma una mappa che sta
cambiando il mondo open street fatta una
mappa a un progetto molto simile a
wikipedia dove tutte le persone possono
contribuire in wikipedia l'obiettivo del
secolo per il nuovo in street ma una
raccolta di dati per creare mappe
ognuno può partecipare come sto
partecipando io e chiunque la persona
che come questa sala e anche fuori da
questa sala per spiegarmi meglio
quant'è contributi li ho costretti come
questo ha coinvolto tantissime persone
voglio usare questo video di the world
che parte adesso il video mostra quattro
anni diversi ogni lampo che vedete sono
contributi le persone che stanno
raccogliendo dati dati che contengono
coordinate queste coordinate a loro
volta descrivono strade edifici e adesso
questa volta di volta in volta poi
vengono aggiunti degli attributi per
definire ad esempio che questa strada è
più stretta più larga con la il limite
di velocità la tipologia di asfalto ma
vendono anche raccolte informazioni
quali i fontanelli dell'acqua anche cose
che vengono raccolte anche per far
presente che esistono come un mio amico
ha trovato un ippodromo abusivo in
sull'italia
come vedete i lampi sono tantissimi era
per sempre utili con sono tantissime
abbiamo raggiunto un milione e 200mila
utenti che adesso stanno di volta in
volta inserendo informazioni interno
della mappa veniamo a trento
questa è una mappa come la vedete a
trento sulla mia destra vedete open
street map sulla sinistra l'idea è
quella di google non sto qua a sindacare
quale qual è più importante delle due
fortunati leggibile l'altra meno
leggibile ma sicuramente quella di
vestito a per ricca di informazioni e
tantissimi dati lo potete vedere
dovete pensare che ognuna di quelle
informazioni che vedete quelle
rappresentazioni sono generosità di
persone che contribuiscono al progetto
si domanda subito chi sono questi
masters persone che raccolgono dati
questo punto hard che sia ma simone
cortesi è stato uno dei pionieri di open
street map in italia durante una più
parti ma che in parte sono momenti in
cui la comunità si incontra raccogliere
dati per poi condividerli gli strumenti
che vengono usate sono più disparati si
tratta di strumenti per raccogliere
notte come vedete se in macchina
fotografica e registratore vocale che
grazie al gps ottengono anche le
coordinate grazie anche a un computer
una foto aerea è possibile tracciare e
ricavare dati tra queste informazioni ce
n'è una che un po fa ridere è uno
scontrino fiscale non è che il messaggio
che voglio dirvi che lo scontrino
fiscale continua dei dati interessanti
che la comunità di costretto apprende
per arricchire ancora di più la mappa lo
scontrino fiscale ad esempio la
tipologia di negozio al numero civico e
amante di questo passo la semplicità con
cui questi dati vengono raccolti e
costruiti permette di fare grandi cose
quando devo spostarmi in africa
esattamente a nairobi kibera chimera una
bidonville 170 mila abitanti molto più
grande che trento comune vero vieta
anche e ci sono gruppo di persone che
stanno raccogliendo dati lì perché è
nuovamente open street map contro google
quella più povera e quella di google
perché non c'è motivo per raccogliere
per far sapere al mondo che che bella
esiste ma la mappa parla da sola lo sta
dicendo su quella mappa li vedete quante
rossi ci sono così rosse che sono punti
di soccorso in cui sabbiosi gente che ha
bisogno di aiuto
il motto di kibera di mappe kibera e
rendere invisibile rendere visibile ciò
che è invisibile
guardate quante informazioni ci sono
necessità che hanno queste persone anche
di coordinarsi infatti ci sono dove sono
le latrine dove sono anche i negozi è
una cosa che mi affascina tantissimo
sono anche i percorsi che hanno nomi
perché quelle persone esistono 170 mila
abitanti hanno da raccontare muoversi
tra un loro territorio
il progetto poi a questo aspetto
umanitario che ha creato un team
ariano costretto a tim famosissimo
durante il terremoto di haiti del 2009
ma attualmente attivissimo nel caso
delle filippine
al momento ci sono 1.300 persone fosse
di più controllato ieri che grazie alle
frontiere aggiornate riescono a
tracciare le nuove mappe delle filippine
perché alcuni edifici esistono più delle
strade sono state interrotte e questa
sono utilissime ai soccorsi umanitari
non serve comunque andare nelle
filippine per capire questo perché lo
sapete benissimo quello che è successo
adesso in sardegna e valentina murtas si
è data da fare per raccogliere
informazioni su quello che sta accadendo
a questo momento in sardegna quei
puntini rossi che vedete sono la
generosità dei saldi per venire in
contro altre persone che sono in
difficoltà per offrire dei punti di
raccolta dei luoghi di ricovero e
trovate tutto questo in questa mappa
questa mappa però a sua volta ha bisogno
di essere arricchita valentina per due
giorni non ha dormito
tant'è che ieri l'ha sentita è svenuta
per cercare di raccogliere questi dati
per renderli disponibili a tutti e ha
chiesto aiuto alla comunità di open
street ma proprio che anche qua ci serve
che la mappa sia giornata in modo che i
soccorsi possono intervenire
e comunque tutta questa generosità che
si sta mettendo in pratica venga
amplificata per permettere a chiunque di
intervenire scappando dal mondo
emergenze
vediamo la situazione propria vicina
all'italia pensiamo ai beni culturali
che l'italia nuovamente le due mappe a
confronto gli scavi di pompei c'è tanta
gente che nel mondo ci guarda con
interesse a questo questo scavo a questo
posto questo luogo non esiste una mappa
che si è ri usabile quando dico
riusabile vuol dire la possibilità di
avere i dati che hanno costruito quella
mappa per poterlo fare in tanti modi
diversi
perché mettendo in evidenza le
informazioni piuttosto che un'altra vi
permette di spiegare meglio quello che
accade e di rivalutare meglio il
territorio
queste queste immagini che vedete sono
immagini pompei è sempre la stessa
la stessa informazione rappresenta in
maniera diversa che addirittura può
arrivare in tre dimensioni
chiaramente è una semplificazione
alessandro un progetto internazionale
questo qua vale anche per trento ed ecco
qualche trento rappresentata in 3d e mi
piace farvi notare che i giardini in
questo momento ci sono dei lavori in
corso e la comunità ha informato di
questo è la rappresentazione 3d sta
riportando poi avere a disposizione i
dati ben sappiamo anche cosa un po più
carine questa qua è ancora prendo sempre
la stessa identica zone fatta con una
rappresentazione ad acquarello la
presentazione acquarello che forse non
potrà esservi nei casi umanitari forse
potrà servire per spiegare meglio quel
che è successo e beni culturali
ma io posso dire che è un mio amico lo
sta usando per le etichette dei suoi
vini una mia amica ha invece aperto una
cartoleria e crea la carta
personalizzata
esattamente come la busta in cui avevi
fatto vedere prima mi sono fatto fare
apposta la busta in cuoio quella mappa
del posto dove lavoro
adesso mi sposto su una cosa molto
medicine ha messo un percorso che è
stato da rovereto a matera la comunità
si incontra si incontrano attraverso una
conferenza che l'italia chiamiamo o
smith dopo quell internazionale stretto
off the map
abbiamo organizzato l'incontro inizi di
ottobre abbiamo fatto questo incontro
anche con la comunità di open street map
di wikipedia chiedo scusa
e questa cosa qua piaciuta tantissimo
alle altre persone
tant'è che i da da potenza è venuta
arrivata alle 4 avete intervento alle
cinque della conferenza insieme alle vs
il mattino semplicemente perché ha
chiesto di ospitare il convegno un'opera
del prossimo anno nella città dei sassi
c'è dietro un motivo
matera è candidata alla città della
cultura europea 2019
per noi della comunitaria per street ma
questa è stata molto interessante perché
c'è un certo senso celebrato si è visto
come un punteggio per fare in modo che
open street map osti cultura ma in
effetti è quello che sto cercando di
dirvi cultura che poi porta ad aumentare
la qualità della vita come caso di
kibera bene il 21 ottobre
mi hanno chiesto di scendere perché non
ha detto sì ci piace ma non siamo così
bravi ci può aiutare a capire come
funziona open street map
anziché fare uno parti si è fatto un
part che è la stessa identica cosa per
un gioco di parole per gli abitanti di
una terra per dire diamoci una mossa
diamoci da fare ma nel risultato è
questo allora nel 2008 la mappa di
matera rea così che mi ha introdotto gli
ho detto che il progetto nasce tra 2004
2005 2008 ma per ora così 2009 strada
principale 2010 2011 2012 2013
io sono sceso il 21 ottobre in 21
ottobre la mappa si presentava così
quattro giorni dopo era così una
settimana dopo così i due settimane dopo
in questo modo la comunità sia data da
fare si è attivata per rendere questa
mappa sempre più importante non è facile
disegnare percorsi di sassi di matera
vi rimando con l'immaginazione la
fotografia di prima e sassi di matera
cercare anche un gruppo un gruppo super
street un'altra che ha iniziato a darsi
da fare su facebook per iniziare a
discutere sono uscite delle cose molto
carine su questo perché ad esempio c'è
qua
angelo che dice che bello ho inserito
alla fontana e sono molto orgoglioso di
questo e seconda questo è molto
importante che le valuto al mio
territorio sono orgoglioso di quello che
sto disegnando piero invece va a dire
guarda c'è un progetto interessante
legato open street map che riguarda
l'accessibilità diamoci da fare su
questo discussione lunghissime che hanno
aumentato la consapevolezza del
territorio che hanno portato poi tante
nuove idee e nato un progetto di
rivalutare gli spazi verdi di matera per
poterli utilizzare come orti urbani
oppure questa strada questa non ferrovia
di matera una ferrovia che non era stata
completata che i cittadini hanno
iniziato a ragionare come può essere
rivista e l'importanza di avere la mappa
è stato fondamentale
bene
settimana scorsa è arrivato un messaggio
da parte dell'assessore dell'innovazione
di matera
l'assessore trani egli ha detto che
matera in via nel finale come città
delle culture europee per me questa cosa
questa molto toccante perché mi sento le
velate un contributo non solo io tutta
la comunità di open street ma perché ci
tengo a dirlo che in questo momento
tutta la comunità si sta organizzando
per aiutare la sardegna
a me non parte mi fa molto piacere che
c'era essere qui anche perché sono di
trento
dall'altra parte vorrei essere attaccato
al computer perché la comodità di un pò
stretto ma italiano in questo momento si
sta organizzando per migliorare i dati
della sardegna e per fare modo che
quella partita ha fatto vedere prima
sardo ss migliori ma io concludo così
spero di vedere qualche vostro
contributo nella mappa devi anche
convinto che questo qua è un grande
vantaggio che comunque può cambiare
veramente la vita di molte persone dando
degli scenari diversi da kibera da
problemi di emergenza dal fatto di poter
dire diventa la capitale della cultura
europea oppure inventarsi anche qualche
nuovo oggetto come quello che vi ho
mostrato prima grazie